there was a major physical
violent attack yesterday in new york in
the subway system
uh the
the information about this attack
was really muddy and really vague the
good news is
that though a gunman walked into a
subway car had gas canisters had gas
masks had guns apparently fired lots of
rounds
only 10 people were shot
and apparently last time i checked the
news on this before the show
no one had died some people were in
critical condition but it was stable
a couple dozen more were injured just
from
people trampling them or from smoke
inhalation or getting off but
this was a major attack
and there's a rule i think maybe it was
ann coulter who came up with this rule
at least she's popularized it
when
when you do not immediately hear about a
suspect's race
or sex or religion
you can know with 100 certainty that the
suspect is not a straight white
christian man
you can just you can know that because
if there's even a chance that the
suspect who's committed the crime
is a straight white christian man that
will be the first thing in the headlines
and frankly even if if the guy who
is is the perpetrator here or the
suspect isn't white
but is plausibly maybe there's a chance
he's white
and a man and straight and christian
you'll see that in the headlines you saw
this notably in the killing of trayvon
martin they said white man kills black
teenager in this neighborhood and he
wasn't a white man george zimmerman's a
hispanic guy and then the new york times
said well he's no he's a white hispanic
guy looks like a hispanic hispanic guy
to me they just got excited because they
saw a name that seemed seemed white they
saw he's a man and so they ran with the
headline
and so the minute i saw we don't know
who the suspect is we don't know it i
said okay well it's not a straight white
christian man i can know that not
because i know anything really about
crime or justice it's just because i
know the media so well and it turns out
that that's right they finally named
a person of interest
frank james still wasn't seeing a ton of
information about him and so frank james
is a 62 year old black guy
who
has expressed radical
racial political views on the internet
here's just one clip that's going around
i had no idea with that african name
that she would be married to
a white man one of my subscribers
brought that to my attention
yeah
our black sister supreme court justice
power to the people is married to a
white man
i don't believe
oh god
wait a minute
can you believe that that awful woman
married to a white man
this guy i think is nuts i watched some
of his other videos and
generally speaking they are not
presenting a coherent political ideology
generally speaking he just seems like a
crazy person and but but he does express
some views on his politics and what he's
expressing is
clearly a black nationalist anti-white
kind of political ideology
i don't even want to say it
i don't do i have to i guess i have to
say it
if the shoe were on the other foot can
you imagine what the media would say i
have to say it just to get just to get
it out there
if there were a similarly crazy white
guy
who said all sorts of crazy things but
then also said i hate it when white guys
marry black women isn't that horrible
that's terrible to the white race
every single headline would be the white
supremacy is a terrible problem in
america we all the white people are so
awful and
we have got too much whiteness and we
got to abolish whiteness and
but you're not going to hear any of that
the absence of that kind of talk here
which i think frankly might even be
merited because i assume the guy
actually is just nuts i don't i don't
know that this is the terror attack of
some political revolutionary genius i
think it's probably a pretty pretty
mentally disturbed guy who also has
pretty disturbed racial and political
views
but the absence the absolute absence of
talk about this of the black nationalism
of the anti-white bigotry
the absence is the indictment and it's
not even the indictment of this guy it's
the indictment of the legacy
establishment liberal media right now go
to goodranchers.com
knowles most people listening to this
show right now have never in their
entire lifetimes seen inflation like we
are seeing right now and that inflation
is particularly pronounced when it comes
to food what if i told you you can
inflation proof your food purchases
right now
forever and i'm specifically talking
about the most important delicious food
you put on the table i'm talking about
beef and better than organic chicken too
but i'm more concerned with that steak
with those burgers with that ground beef
you can subscribe right now to good
ranchers they already have ridiculously
low prices for fabulous quality meat
amazing american beef and meat from from
american ranches and you just get locked
into that price forever and you get
another 30 discount on top of that
for their prime steaks for their better
than organic chicken the way to do it
it's not too good to be true this is for
our listeners go to goodranchers.com
knowles to save on the quality you've
been looking for good ranchers takes all
the guesswork out of the grocery store
sources everything locally use code noel
skinner can wles
on your box of 100 american meat and you
will get your 30 savings i suggest you
subscribe you can also buy the boxes one
off to give it a try order now to combat
inflation with good ranchers american
meat delivered
i'm glad you like that clip now
ring the bell subscribe get those
notifications we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you